what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
clip from the roommates podcast
um it says shan shane i think shan
body booty body i don't even know
explains why beautiful women struggle
with dating before i start do not forget
to subscribe to the channel you guys
already know i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers okay let's
so the video is titled why
beautiful women struggle with dating and
i picked this one someone sent this to
me on my instagram
because this is something i noticed when
i was like younger
was that like the prettiest girls i know
like literally always got cheated on
so it'll be interesting to see what this
girl's take on that is
i'm like okay the same thing was
happening with me with dating i still
wasn't having those great connections i
was getting a lot of my own ways i was
getting ghosted i just
i wasn't finding joy in that and so i
started studying pickup artistry
and seduction and influence and
connection and that transformed my life
in every way
and i thought how do i package all these
great books into an interesting read
like i think it's quite fascinating just
even you talking about struggles in
dating because you're obviously a very
beautiful woman
very intelligent yeah and
and so most people wouldn't assume that
you would have some challenges like what
were some of the challenges that you
were facing consistently i don't know if
you guys are on instagram
every hot girl complains about dating
the hottest like i said that about
brittany raynor whose book um judge's
cover came out
and i was like this is such an
affirmation like if this woman has a
ass like a coffee table and still has
tables
huh i like coffee tables yeah it was a
it's a very nice very very nice
authentic
coffee table oh yeah i can't tell you
touched it no
i've seen the gym i'm not i'm really
really not an aficionado at what is or
isn't real i'm not good at that stuff
but i would assume i see the gym work i
mean whatever i don't i don't know
it looks wonderful um it's whatever form
but i would say that like if there's no
face of
what somebody who's a bad connector
looks like and that's
what the artist deduction teaches you is
that there's nine different ways to be
highly seductive and to
be great at connecting with others only
one of those has to do with how you look
and looks is a depreciating asset and
there's a study that was done that's
like there's no proof
that people who date somebody who's hot
have relationship satisfaction
yeah if anything i would guess it's the
opposite
because that's why you see hollywood all
of their marriages literally fail
like every single one have you heard the
study where it says is actually
like sometimes the more attractive you
are the
the more difficult it is for you to find
somebody in a romantic relationship have
you ever read that before
i wonder if it's because they will feel
like their partner is replaceable would
you guys say that's true or false let me
know in the comments
oh it's quite fascinating yeah i would
say it is but i mean i was also
a dick you know what i mean like yeah
i um i've never got along with teachers
my whole life i'm a very disagreeable i
would say like
someone actually said to me because when
i started you know doing sex as a career
that sounds like a prostitution
that's how my parents interpreted it
actually when i started you know talking
about sex as a career at like
19 20 years old my parents were so
angry and upset with it and against him
my mom's reaction was so
visceral and i didn't give a [ __ ] and so
a part of my
the reason i even have this career is
because i'm a dick i'm like i don't care
anyone else thinks i'm going to do it
but that that's the thing too is a lot
of the qualities that we have at your
point that aid us in certain areas in
life
actually prevent us from being
successful in others and so okay
interesting thing i was always very
jealous
of girls that were like higher on the
disagreeable scale because
i felt like they like didn't take [ __ ]
from anybody they like
told people off if they were you know
acting a certain way like i always
really envied that quality
but what i realized is i'm if i took a
test like scale one to ten i'm like 70
on the agreeableness scale and i
realized that's actually what made me
like have
long-term friendships and like that was
why people liked me so i went from like
disliking that about myself to like
realizing that even if you're
disagreeable like it comes with a
different
set of problems that headstrong i'm
doing things my way i don't care
anyone's things
this is who i am take it or leave it
really helped to propel or start my
career
yeah but it was stopping me from making
healthy romantic connections
so i had to acknowledge at one point
that i'm like the common denominator is
you
you know like every sandwich you go to
you get an argument
every airplane you're on every
relationship you're in like
and agreeableness is the number one
trait which determines relationship
longevity and success or someone's
ability
which we're told nice people finished
last but in truth nice people stay in
the race the longest
dang that's really interesting so the
people with the longest relationships
tend to be higher on the agreeableness
scale
that's that's a really i've never heard
that before
um never heard it so the traits that you
saw
like what what made you change how did
you start going through that process
with some of the things that you did
it's troubleshooting when you're like oh
something's not working and then you can
do the troubleshooting what a lot of
people do
where they're like other other other men
ain't [ __ ] this person ain't [ __ ]
the world ain't [ __ ] dating ain't [ __ ]
you can do that for a while
and i did that for a while and
eventually i was like
maybe that's true maybe dating is [ __ ]
maybe it is hard maybe it is trash
but there are people who are doing well
yeah i can't deny that there are people
who have success in this area i'm just
not one of them
and if i want to be one of those
successful people i got to start paying
attention to what they're doing that i'm
not
and that's where books came into play
are just being an observer being a
listener and a learner and being
able to make important changes in my
life and my own personality and then
i think that's when i had a massive
shift
no this is very true like you kind of
have two choices
in life when it comes to a certain point
you can either like blame the world
or you can realize that you're the
common denominator and literally all
these scenarios
was the biggest thing that you changed
that you felt like caused the most
drastic shift in your life
um my disagreeableness like i honestly
would say like
i'm married now and my number one advice
for
like a healthy marriage is like
developing your shut the [ __ ] up filter
she's funny oh my god she's funny or say
how i would do things or give an
alternate route
like i'm just like always yeah and then
if i just be quiet sometimes and even
if something it doesn't please me you
know sometimes i want to correct right
away
but if i just be quiet one sometimes it
actually pans out even better than i
thought it would
or number two it's like let that person
have the joy of having
their vision come to fruition just like
you want to assert your vision in this
moment like they also want that same
feeling of knowing they did it their way
so like shutting up and like shutting
down that voice in my head which you
know stopped me from being a good
student
where i was always trying to one-up the
teacher or say how things could be
better
but versus like if i'm trusting you to
partner with you i actually
have to trust you um so that was my
biggest shift
it's actually really interesting because
she kind of gives me like
um feminist vibes i don't know just like
i've heard a couple of her clips like
from different areas so it's really
interesting
like her take on how she went from being
like extremely unsuccessful
to successful do you guys have something
like that for yourself that you
recognize like
oh my gosh i'm gonna go down the road
trust me
i mean man um for me the biggest thing
that i saw um
[Music]
that hold on what are you asking me
what was the trait that was blocking
your own blessing
years later okay that was an interesting
clip i
yeah i think that's like actually she
had a lot
of insights that were really interesting
especially that people higher with the
trait
agreeableness tend to have longer
relationships that's really interesting
let me know in the comments if you agree
or you disagree what do you think
is the key to a long and healthy
relationship and do not forget to
subscribe i'll talk to you guys
next time